تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقاطع
فيديو لابقار برازيليه تجوب شوارع مدينه
الرباط المغربيه مما اثار الفزع بين
المواطنين ولكن سرعان ما تحركت الحكومه
المغربيه واتخذت الاجراءات اللازمه
والسيطره على الموقف
[موسيقى]
ومن المشاهد والمقاطع الاكثر انتشارا على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي اكبر افطار جماعي
في الجزائر الذي شارك فيه حوالي ثلاثه
الاف صائم وبلغ طول المائده حوالي كيلو
مترا واحد
[موسيقى]
قطع محتاجون الرئيس الفرنسي امانيويل
ماكرون اثناء كلمته حول مستقبل اوروبا في
هولندا وهم يحملون لافتات كتب عليها رئيس
العنف والنفاق ما ادى الى طردهم خلال
الخطاب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مراقبه عمليه سرقه لاموال التبرعات من
مسجد في تركيا حيث كان المسجد خاليا من
المصلين وحاول اللص فتح صندوق التبرعات
باستخدام سلك حديد لكن عندما شاهده احد
القادمين تظاهر بالصلاه وعلى الفور جاءت
الشرطه واعتقلت
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء اليوم الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات